Hey Wisecrack, Jared here. Today we’ve got
a self-­aware, fourth­-wall-­breaking spectacular
for you. That’s right, we’re talking about Deadpool.
Deadpool is experiencing unprecedented popularity
in mainstream media. The film is the highest
grossing R­-rated movie ever, and the
biggest opening for Ryan Reynolds, but I guess
that part isn’t a surprise. How has this
film achieved such success despite shirking
the traditional superhero formula?
"Bob? I haven't seen you since-"
"Jacksonville."
Fighting for the greater good? Nope. Selfless?
Not really. Fun for the whole family? Uh...
"I'm touching myself tonight."
No.
For a Marvel character who is an overt ripoff
of a DC competitor that constantly makes fun
of the medium that he inhabits, the merc with
a mouth is doing pretty well for himself.
Deadpool’s popularity represents a trend
in media that may be gaining steam lately,
but is otherwise quite old. And it all has
to do with a 400 year old book, sort of.
I’m an arrogant asshole and welcome to this
Wisecrack Edition on The Philosophy of Deadpool.
Part 1: Achieving Fuck It
There are a few defining features that set
Deadpool apart from the rest of the Marvel
universe. He’s an inveterate wiseass,
he knows he’s a superhero and is, as a result,
constantly breaking the fourth wall and commenting
on comic book tropes and culture.
Deadpool takes nothing seriously.
Even the ad campaign for the film was imagined in an entirely Deadpoolian fashion.
The film’s Valentine’s Day ads
were simultaneously a great way to troll soon­-to-­be
furious partners and a set­up for a self­-referential
joke. They even created a Tinder profile.
Perhaps the best way to describe Deadpool
is as a postmodern work. Let me explain.
Postmodernism is a movement in the arts and
philosophy that typically rejects the kind
of grand narratives used to make sense of
the world in the good old days. For instance,
the battle of good against evil, democracy
against communism, the inherent promise of
technological progress, science or divine
salvation, the very idea of “the good old days”.­
You get the idea. Postmodern
works are quick to thumb their nose at tradition
and have a tendency to embrace being “meta”
and self­-reference.
Deadpool is hyper-­aware of himself and his
place in the superhero genre.
The film is full of Ryan Reynolds jokes, like the reference
to the cinematic abomination “The Green Lantern",
his face on People Magazine’s “Sexiest
Man Alive” or the face of his vastly more
appreciated counterpart ­ also on People
Magazine.
If the grand narrative that permeates superhero
films is the triumph of good over evil, Deadpool,
in good postmodern fashion, says “fuck it
­ let’s go bowling,” I mean, killing.
Wrong movie - same idea. There is no grand
battle of good over evil, just a guy out there
killing a bunch of people for revenge and
love.
This tension, between the old world and postmodernism,
is played out in a couple different ways in
the film. Colossus is constantly asking Deadpool
to cut out the shenanigans and join the X­Men,
as if to rope him into the role of a good
superhero, family friendly, righteous, and so on.
Likewise, the Dopinder subplot subverts
classic narratives of courtly love. Win the
heart of your beloved through chivalry and
compassion? Nah. It’s more effective to
to just kidnap her current lover and stuff
him in the trunk. Even Blind Al is essentially
a deranged version of a classic narrative.
Deformed protagonist who takes refuge with
a benevolent blind benefactor? Yep sounds
familiar, except this time…
Not to mention that the apple of our hero's eye isn't a fair
maiden. She's a prostitute turned stripper.
In this way, Deadpool can be seen as a spiritual
successor to a 400 ­year-­old novel that
also made fun of the heroes of its eras, employed
meta-narratives, and is called by some a proto­-postmodern
work: Don Quixote. Remember that the story
of Don Quixote is the tale of a fictional
author who discovered the fictional accounts
of Don Quixote, a story within a story, way
before The Blair Witch project. Don Quixote understands he is being written about,
and the fictional author
retelling his tale constantly breaks the fourth wall.
At one point in Don Quixote, the story
just cuts off when the fictional author claims
the rest of the story was lost. We’re not
saying this parallel is intentional, but it is
worth noting that Deadpool kills Don Quixote
in the comic books.
To understand Don Quixote’s relation
to Deadpool, we have to understand its historical
context. Don Quixote was written at a time
when radical skepticism of the existing order
started to bud in popular society. It was
written just before the Enlightenment gripped Europe,
which would respond to this skepticism
by touting the virtues of rationality and science.
But Don Quixote wasn’t setting
out to invent a new ideology: he just wanted
to have a few laughs at the expense of Spanish
society.
Deadpool signals a similar disenchantment
with all those old righteous narratives in
our society. But this time it’s a little different, and whether or not it’s a good thing is up for debate.
Part 2: Ironic Distance and Cynicism
In a recent interview, Joss Whedon, the man
behind such self­-aware titles as Firefly,
Buffy and the Avengers, finds in Indiana Jones
a microcosm for all that’s wrong with today’s culture.
In the original Indiana Jones film, our protagonist
famously deals with a gratuitous display of
swordsmanship with a modest display of marksmanship. In the Temple of Doom, we’re confronted
with a similar scene but, oh my, there’s
now two swordsmen. Indie reaches for his gun,
but it’s not there. He delivers a shit­eating-­grin
to the audience, as if to say, “see what
I did there? You saw that last movie, and
I made an inside joke about it. I’m so glad
we had this moment together, now that you
feel like you’re in on this collective joke
that doesn’t even make sense because Temple
of Doom is a fucking prequel.”
That moment of self-­reference for the sake of self-­reference, Whedon says, has engulfed our culture.
Film, television, literature ­it’s all becoming that
moment.
This self­awareness is increasingly taking
a cynical tone. It’s almost everywhere you
look. In the new Tarzan trailer, a reboot/remake/adaptation of a film nobody asked for,
Jane overtly references the fact that she’s playing the tired role of a damsel in distress.
Now what really chaps my ass about this is that the film is recognizing that it’s using tired recycled tropes, but
instead of doing something new, it simply
apologizes for it, and expects us to perceive
this self awareness as something clever and
new. The end of Star Trek Into Darkness is
just an excuse to say “Hey ­remember this
great scene in cinema? Now it’s opposite day!”
22 Jump Street is the same exact plot
as 21 Jump Street, but it’s ok, because
we can collectively identify with Ice Cube
for calling them out on their bullshit.
Or, as South Park frames it:
As if to out­-meta each other, this cynical
attitude has transcended self­-reference
into self-­effacement. Hollywood, that decrepit
machine fueled by the ideas of yesteryear,
is always stuck referencing itself. In an
effort reinvent itself while still remaining
the same, it gleefully acknowledges its lazy
cliches, with a wink and a nod, like in Tarzan,
or by employing irony to undercut a dramatic
moment.
Deadpool does both.
It breaks the fourth wall to let us in on
the joke and it avoids serious drama like
the plague. Hollywood still employs familiar
structures and tropes, but distances
the audience from any kind of sincerity so
that it feels new.
Is this Hollywood version of #sorrynotsorry gratifying for the viewer,
or have we just come to terms with the fact
that there is nothing new to say?
Deadpool’s humor is largely driven by this
sense of cynicism and ironic distance. Whether
he’s being tortured, or about to be gruesomely
maimed, Deadpool remains unphased in the face
of what would normally be considered high
stakes situations. Even the tension of combat
scenes are undercut by self­aware humor.
Also ­he can’t die so that probably helps.
If Deadpool is immune to criticism, it’s
because he is defined by his cynicism. He
relentlessly deconstructs any trope that would
endow meaning to film. Deadpool is more or
less Wade Wilson’s journey to become hot
again, itself a shallow endeavor, even if
to reclaim his lost love­ or really lust. Deadpool
evades criticism become he has no moral scruples
or values to defend,
his identity is purely
reactionary.
He risks nothing. He just makes fun of everything.
Deadpool doesn’t claim to be a good guy.
The film also has 0 fucks to give. Its ad
campaign doesn’t take itself seriously and
the movie points out its glaring flaws: The
overuse of superhero tropes,
or the obvious budgetary constraints.
I mean, Negasonic Teenage Warhead
is the Marvel Universe equivalent of a Walmart
bargain bin DVD. But just because the movie
is aware of, and sort of apologizes for, it’s lacking qualities,
does that make it good?
I have to admit, I’m conflicted here. On
the one hand, I find Deadpool’s self­reflective
edgy commentary to be undeniably enjoyable.
At the end of the day, Ryan Reynolds is damn
charming, the action is awesome, and the jokes
are disarming and quite fun. But then again,
should we really give so much praise to a
movie that essentially functions like an Honest
Trailer for other comic book movies?
Therein lies a danger with this trend: it
never creates anything. An obsession
with being meta that devolves into an endless
spiral of meta.
In this way, Deadpool isn’t
entirely dissimilar from another cultural
movement: one that ironically loves the cliche,
endlessly recycles culture and constantly
positions itself against the mainstream­­-hipsters.
As Douglas Haddow once aptly noted, the danger
of the hipster is the end of Western civilization
itself, “a culture lost in the superficiality
of its past and unable to create any new meaning.”
Deadpool isn’t reinventing the superhero
genre, it can only exist to make fun of the genre.
Here’s the real problem with Deadpool
and other films like it. Bashing the system
may feel good, it may make us laugh, but it’s
ultimately powerless­ it doesn’t change
the system at all.
As our old friend and alleged Mark Hamill
body­double Slavoj Zizek notes, “cynical
distance, laughter, irony, are, so to speak,
part of the game. The ruling ideology is not
meant to be taken seriously or literally.”
Hipsters fancy themselves
members of the counterculture by drinking
PBR and having ironic mustaches. Deadpool
fancies itself a countercultural movie by
celebrating its own played-­out cliches and
an overused storyline, the cinematic equivalents of gross hipster mustaches and non-­prescription glasses.
This cultural impasse reflects a society that
doesn’t quite know what to do with itself.
We beat the Commies, our music, film and literature
dominate the world market, and as a society
we’re not exactly on the brink of collapse
­ despite what political pundits are telling you.
If Deadpool can say “Fuck it,” it’s
because he doesn’t fear death. How can he
take anything seriously when there are no consequences? Can life be sacred when it has become
limitless? Hell, if the superhero genre survived
these dumpster fires, then maybe it can’t
die either­ so fuck it. Why not break all
the rules?
Interestingly, the very sanctity-­breaking
of the comic book was inspired a similar problem.
Except, rather than feeling that Deadpool
the comic was uncancellable, they felt it
would be cancelled at any minute. What ensued
was a similar attitude of “fuck it,” if
the comic was already dead, why not write
it like nothing mattered?
If we, as a society, can say “fuck it,” perhaps it’s because death or really any real existential threat
has become either so
distance, or so close that we no longer care.
So where does Deadpool land in our cultural
landscape? Does it just use the fourth wall
breaking to put a shiny makeover over the
same old shit? Is it the ultimate cynical
film? Or does it actually achieve something
new? Let us know what you think in the comments.